and yeah I'm gonna be taking a second
from social media and I will see you
guys
um sooner and later I just I'm gonna
just take a break from everything Selena
Gomez steps back from social media I'm
very lucky that I have a platform I have
it's been a busy week for the 30 year
old who found herself at the center of
multiple rumored feuds I'm very honest
though in general and online attacks
about her appearance leading to an
emotional message on Thursday
um I'm good I love who I am I don't care
I'm big I'm not I would I don't I don't
care
I love who I am while chatting with her
fans on Tick Tock live Selena announces
she's staying off social media for now
and yeah I'm gonna be taking a second
from social media because
it's this is a little silly
and I'm 30 I'm too old for this so
but I love you guys so much
I'm at that age where I feel like that's
what matters is making sure I'm healthy
and people are happy that I love this
comes after Selena's long Hiatus from
Instagram when her assistant had control
of her account I haven't been on the
internet in four and a half years it has
changed my life completely she returned
to the gram last month and by doing so
reclaimed her title as the most followed
woman on the platform boasting 382
million followers she takes the crown
back from Kylie Jenner the previous
record holder but there's no fight for
the throne in fact earlier this week
Selena and the reality star worked
together to squash a rumored beef
accidentally laminated my brows too much
after this beauty post from Selena Kylie
shared snaps of her and Haley Bieber's
eyebrows leading to speculation they
were mocking Selena who previously dated
Haley's husband Justin Bieber the beauty
Mogul quickly stepped in telling fans
this is reaching no shade towards Selena
ever and I didn't see her eyebrow posts
deep down like I would love my true fans
to know all my personal stuff Selena
also swooped in to clear the air writing
agreed Kylie Jenner it's all unnecessary
I'm a fan of Kylie but the drama didn't
stop there after brow gate a clip
resurfaced online of Haley dissing sells
bestie Taylor Swift one of the meanest
lyrics about a celebrity since Taylor
Swift's last album
you betcha
you betcha after the clip blew up on
Tick Tock cell gave her two cents in the
comments writing so sorry my best friend
is and continues to be one of the best
in the game on social media it's as much
as it's a blessing and it's fun it it
can really tear people down and I always
thought that the people I'm involved
with or support me can just kind of
spread love within that yeah and when
the Love on social media isn't felt it's
time to hit the brakes I'm very happy
I'm so blessed I'm the best friends the
best fans in the whole world and I just
can be happier and I will see you guys
um sooner than later I just I'm gonna
just take a break from everything
foreign